المرحلة الجديدة التي أعلنها الجيش الإسرائيلي
الآن، ترك
هونا ثاني أكبر مدينة في غزة في حالة من الفوضى وتدمير أجزاء منها، هذا أحد
سكان هنا يبحث في
أنقاض هذا المنزل بعد
غارة إسرائيلية، يقول هامي طنيرة إن 30 شخصًا كانوا
داخل المنزل معظمهم من
الأطفال، قال الجيش الإسرائيلي
صباح الأربعاء  لقد نفذت
حوالي 250 غارة جوية في غزة خلال الـ
24 ساعة الماضية، وهي الآن
تبث في قلب مدينة هان يونس تطلب من
المدنيين إخلاء أجزاء من المدينة.
يحتوي هذا المنشور الإسرائيلي على آية
من القرآن تشير بشكل مشؤوم إلى نبوءة
نوح.  تحذير من أن فيضانًا قادمًا،
اجتاحهم الطوفان بينما
استمروا في ارتكاب
الأخطاء، ما لا يتدفق إلى غزة
يكفي مساعدات حذرت إدارة بايدن
إسرائيل بشدة من أنها لا
تفعل ما يكفي وتأمل الولايات المتحدة في رؤية
تغيير في إسرائيل  التكتيكات العسكرية
خلال هذه المرحلة الجديدة لا تزال تقتل عددًا كبيرًا جدًا من
المدنيين الفلسطينيين المدنيين،
نريد أن نرى عدد القتلى المدنيين
أقل مما كان عليه، نريد أن
نرى عدد القتلى المدنيين أقل مما هو
عليه اليوم، أقل مما كان عليه في
الأيام القليلة الماضية  في شمال غزة، قال الجيش الإسرائيلي
اليوم إنه عثر على مخبأ كبير
للأسلحة بما في ذلك صواريخ وقذائف صاروخية
وجميع أنواع
المتفجرات، وبينما توسع إسرائيل
وتكثف عملياتها، لا يزال 138 رهينة
في الأسر، مع تعطل المحادثات بشأن
إطلاق سراحهم من خلال
تسجيلات جديدة صدرت يوم الأربعاء.
مواجهات غاضبة بين
الرهائن المفرج عنهم وعائلات الرهائن في
اجتماع مع رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو، اتهمه البعض بإعطاء
الأولوية للسياسة، وقالوا إن
قصف الجيش لغزة يهدد
حياة الرهائن اتهمت رهينة سابقة لا يزال
زوجها في الأسر
نتنياهو بعدم وجود
معلومات استخباراتية عن الوضع.
مواقع الرهائن كان الشعور الذي كان لدينا هناك هو
أنه لا أحد يفعل أي شيء من أجلنا،
قالت الحقيقة هي أنني كنت مختبئًا
في مكان تعرض للقصف وكان لا بد من
تهريبنا إلى الخارج وأصبنا
في وقت ما، صرخ نتنياهو
من العار قالت امرأة أخرى
لوزير الدفاع أنا لست على استعداد
للتضحية بابني من أجل مسيرتك، ابني
لم يتطوع للموت دفاعا عن
الوطن كان مواطنا
اختطف من منزله من سريره وتعرض
نتنياهو للضغط من قبل  الرهائن
وعائلاتهم للإفراج عن المزيد من
الأسرى الفلسطينيين مقابل
الرهائن المتبقين
رد نتنياهو بأنه سمع حزنهم
لكنه ادعى أن حماس تريد ثمناً أعلى
من مجرد
السجناء الفلسطينيين، ومضى يقول إن
الضغط العسكري الإسرائيلي أه هو الذي
حصل  بعد إطلاق سراح الموجة الأولى من الرهائن،
نشهد الآن هذا الضغط مرة
أخرى في غزة مع تقدم الجيش الإسرائيلي
جنوبًا داخل قطاع غزة. أليكس ماركارد سي
إن إن تل أبيب